the lefty colby allard getting the start
here this afternoon for the rangers a
two and two record with a 2.91 era
well his 02.
this one lying to short and right there
for it tyner falefa one away
[Applause]
a little tapper back toward the mound
allard hustles it over to first takes
care of buxton
[Applause]
swinging a miss and crew strikes out and
what a nice tidy first inning for colby
allerty gets it done on 10 pitches randy
dobneck on the mound for the twins this
afternoon he's making his fifth start so
he's pitching a contact and he's trying
to get ground balls
this ball rifled down the third baseline
that'll be extra bases for kinder
philippa
larnick picks it up in the corner not
before isaiah has himself a lead off
double he's not getting the weak contact
that he's used to
back to dobneck and they've got the lead
runner trapped
and that
extra throw may allow the runner to
advance to second base
he will hold at first base so they got
the lead runner
deep to the left field corner
and caught in the corner by larnick and
domdak does a nice job with damage
control stranding the lead-off double
at the strikeout of cruz to end it the
1-2 pitch to larnick and he gets him
swinging then a strikeout begins the
second one away a lot of talent there
and a lot of power in his bat 13 home
runs 32 rbis
but he strikes out swinging here and
that is a third strikeout already
for allard and another efficient inning
2-2
and a swing of the miss another
strikeout for allard his fourth this
afternoon
first pitch to arise he swings first
pitch and slices one in the air to left
white drifts over in fair territory with
the backhand he makes the catch and
that's the end of the inning
3-2 pitch
and that is ball four charlie sold that
one and the rangers have one out base
runner for isaiah kind of left it
this ball hit well out to left field
larnick looks up that's
[Applause]
and the rangers start the scoring this
afternoon
this was an absolute line shot off the
bat of isaiah connor falefa
good fastball to get a ground ball
simmons
starts a double play sharply hit but a
ground ball double play ends the third
the rangers score two on the keiner
falepa home run
[Applause]
backhanded nice slide soul comes up
firing buxton
looking like the hip flexors just fine
my goodness nelson cruz struck out
swinging his first time up
here's a drive to center field off the
bat of cruz
tie game
nelson cruz with his 15th home run of
the year and just like that the twins
have tied it up that was a really good
swing by nelson cruz he got that cutter
the opposing pitcher he did not miss any
part of that ball right there
two two swing and a miss there's the
change up we got jeffers chasing
one two pitch and this one back up the
middle
kenner falefa will take it to the bag
himself forced out to know and the
inning is done but the twins
have even the score
one strike offering of this one on the
ground and threw into left field that's
a base hit for solac rangers fourth hit
of the ball game now
chopper to third and rise throws on the
run to suno and that ends
the bottom of the fourth inning and we
end to the fifth tied at two
now big hit another 0-2 head
seems like we've had
a month's worth of those in this series
already
and a really good match up here between
colby allard and byron buxton this is
strike pitch and they struck him out
allard with his
what sixth strike out of the game
broken back roller to second and
culverson beats it out
polanco did not get a clean exchange
and a pitch ground ball missed by
domnick underhand flipped to simmons
back to first
in time
[Applause]
[Applause]
right field that should make for a clean
sixth inning it does
in that six what an afternoon
for howard
[Applause]
and kepler will take a one-hour
walk in the dirt and kepler took off and
he'll get a stolen base
and a rising advance
and
kepler does that it almost hit a rise in
the ankle two outs and if you're the
twins you could do a lot worse than
having luisa rise dig in a wild pitch
3-1
oh that one
gets away from the catcher and now here
comes kepler with the go ahead run it
was ball four
it nearly hit a rise
back to back wild pitches
and the twins take the lead here in the
seventh
without a base head
[Applause]
drinking ball or that cutter getting a
swinging strike three one away
and a cutter gets a little pop up short
left
and
larnick
with simmons crouching out of the way
and coleman enjoys a one two three seven
the last base runner
was in the fifth this one into right
field that's a base hit
and heim is on to start the bottom of
the eighth
not going
and this one on the ground that's
through the left field base hit
so now
tying runners in scoring position
got it
shaved the outside corner with a
breaking ball
a couple of hits are left to board and
we head to the ninth with the twins up
3-2
[Applause]
he strikes out ceno for out number two
he's a baseball player but boy you look
like you put a set of pads on him it'd
be a good full-back i don't know too
many full-backs that have a change-up
like this though dave it's a finesse
pitch
now o2 pitch
this one sharply hit down to first nice
pick by low
and they get kepler two in the inning so
king with another scoreless frame
well ninth inning now last chance for
the rangers one to tie two to win
this one on the ground and that one is
through base hit so lack is on
second hit of the game for nick solak
tying run aboard in the ninth
oh man what a knifing cutting fastball
gee two down
high fly right center field
buxton puts it away and the twins win a
close one again
against the texas rangers and have now
won three in a row in a well-pitched
ball game